tesla has gone from being what was
considered to be a playboy's gimmick
company to being arguably the most
successful american car maker in the
world and part of that success has
always been their ability to push fresh
things out in time to keep people
interested however with the way things
have been going well broadly speaking in
every direction it looks like tesla
might have to slow down on their success
train today we are going to be talking
about what is up with the tesla delays
what caused it what it means for
customers as well as how it will impact
the company and the industry moving
forward if you want to learn more please
keep watching because this video will
cover a lot what's going on if you've
been out of the tesla circle for a while
or are just new in general because let's
face it there are a lot more people
coming into the fandom these days which
as we'll realize through the course of
the video is part of why the delays are
happening but let's not get ahead of
ourselves okay so a few months ago tesla
website frequenters and new buyers
started noticing that the estimated time
of delivery for the models had suddenly
increased by a large margin and it
wasn't just random but across the board
what used to be a week-long wait had now
gone on to be a wait time of three
months or longer to be specific the
estimated delivery date for model 3 is
in december while model y prospective
buyers have to wait till february of
next year and the cream of the crop the
model s and model x now have an even
longer wait time till march or april of
2022 and that's over the continuous
delays that are already faced by the
models that are yet to be produced
namely the cyber truck semi roadster and
the upper end performance versions of
models 3 and y which are now estimated
to arrive in november 2022 now although
tesla has never been known for super
fast delivery these delays have been
shocking for a bunch of reasons because
basically as of this moment there aren't
any major tesla cars that anyone can buy
in fact the issue isn't limited to tesla
alone either with companies like ford
honda gm and volkswagen all having been
caught off guard by this mysterious
delay in production and so the question
has to be asked what exactly is it
that's causing the sudden slowing down
of the automaker industry well the
answer lies in two factors the first one
being the demand and the second being a
global shortage in the manufacturing of
a bunch of supplies that are necessary
for car manufacturing but before we get
into any of those let's first tackle the
issue of demand in its heyday tesla was
a company for enthusiasts meaning that
the only people who ever bought those
cars were people who had a personal
passion for ev and what elon was doing
however as time has gone on the global
perspective on electric vehicles
especially tesla has gone from a fad to
the actual future of the industry and
since tesla is by far the most iconic
company of this ev wave they have gone
from an unknown brand to being one of
the most recognizable status symbols in
the country with celebrities and
billionaires alike taking a keen
interest in the machines couple that
with the increasing government
incentives for buying an ev and it's
safe to say that tesla's have never been
more in demand than they are now and
that's where we run into our main issue
you see although musk did want his
company to succeed the shift has been so
dramatic that the tesla supply is still
a little ways behind the demand not to
mention with tesla's new ventures
growing from solar to battery all of
their new resources have not been going
to making cars as a result right now the
tesla demand exceeds their maximum
supply by a large margin and as orders
pile up the problem is only going to get
worse and do you realize how ironic that
is slowed down by the pace of your
success now that's a paradox while that
problem is limited to tesla and will be
fixed because it is tesla we're talking
about and they always have a plan the
other problem is a lot more serious and
a lot more far-reaching the global part
shortage let's face it the past two
years have been the absolute worst
setback that humanity has faced in years
and the virus isn't the only thing that
has contributed to it because as it
turns out a u.s china trade scuffle back
in september of 2020 has led to one of
the worst chip shortages that the world
has ever seen while a few decades ago
that would have been bad but not
terrible in a world that is getting
exceedingly more digital that is a death
sentence for many industries and you
guessed it car manufacture particularly
large-scale electric cars which rely
heavily on those chips is one of those
industries and not just chips raw
materials radars batteries and
everything has been going down causing
more and more bottlenecking tweeting
regarding the tesla roadster shortage
musk himself admitted that 2021 has been
the year of super crazy supply chain
shortages assuming 2022 is not mega
drama new roadster should ship in 2023
and later on in july this year at the
company's second quarter earnings call
musk said that chip supply is
fundamentally the governing factor in
our output it is difficult for us to see
how long this will last because this is
out of our control essentially for the
rest of this year our growth rates will
be determined by the slowest part in our
supply chain what all of this means is
that basically tesla simply can't get
their hands on the building materials
needed for making a car and if the rest
of the industry doesn't fix itself soon
tesla might have to delay production
even further now what exactly do both of
these things mean for the company and
the customers well the first part is
incomplete cars now if you thought that
the problem would only affect the future
you're dead wrong because in reality the
problem is so bad in fact that already
several tesla owners have been reporting
missing parts inside their teslas there
have been missing wireless charging pads
as well as usb ports which might not be
as bad as bmw owners not getting their
touchscreen and while tesla does promise
that they'll install all of that as soon
as parts arrive the real problem is the
fact that a majority of these missing
parts were without notifying the
customer and then there's tesla's
autopilot now traditionally that has
been done using cameras as well as radar
and while tesla eventually wanted to
switch to cameras only the eventual
transfer has happened much earlier and
while many will consider that a good
thing since it's supposed to be superior
these new cars are shockingly incomplete
with the autopilot messing up far more
than it used to many are theorizing that
this hurried shift has also been due to
the chip shortage and the second effect
has been delays we already covered part
of the delays but taking a deeper look
at them makes you realize a lot more
interesting stuff first off besides
pushing the model s long range and the
model x long range to march 2023 the
company seems to be forcing people to
buy only specific car configurations
here's what we mean the 19-inch wheels
have been the cheapest and standard
option for a while the configurator now
shows the bigger and more expensive
21-inch arachnid wheels as default and
wouldn't you know it that increases the
price by 4500
but also makes the delivery faster with
the november 2022 delivery timeline
meaning once again that there is a
shortage in parts in this case the
wheels the same can be said in the case
of the top performance version model s
plaid which can be bought as early as
december 2021 regardless of the choice
of wheels or color the situation over at
cyber cybertruck is even more depressing
with the online configurator having been
removed entirely and that brings us to
the price you see tesla's most recent
release the model y suv was categorized
as a cheap standard suv for the masses
starting near a respectable 48 000
however over the past year or so that
price has gone up by a whopping 10 000
and the same can be expected of cyber
truck since its shockingly competitive
price of 39 grand was already pretty
hard to pull off with the new delays it
is easy to see why the company has
chosen to remove any mention of the
price from their website all in all
things are looking pretty grim for the
ev giant however there is still some
hope in the form of the future now with
the way things have been going it's
pretty hard to make solid claims about
what's up for the company but there are
a few good points the first is the new
car factories in houston and austin both
of which will be centered around the
production of large volume low-cost
vehicles and where those will take a
large share of the burden from the
current factories there is also tesla's
upcoming battery rollover the new 4680
cells and the associated gigafactories
have already been showing great signs of
completely removing the battery
constraint and as construction draws to
a close that is looking nearer as well
all in all while we don't think the
delays will be redacted there is still a
decent amount of hope for the tesla
fanboys out there and on that note we
must end today's video i hope you
enjoyed watching it and if you did be
sure to leave a like and subscribe for
more and with that take care and i'll
see you guys next time